hello I'm John Oliver host of last week
tonight we're still off this week but we
wanted to check in with you regarding
the presidential election or as it's now
better known Uncle Sam's Rock Bottom
Yankee Doodle suicide pact at this point
in the year our field of presidential
candidates are racking up endorsements
Hillary Clinton has been endorsed by
Gloria Steinem Stevie Wonder and Oprah
who you may remember I recently replaced
as the queen of daytime talk
in-your-face Oprah in your face
sorry Oprah meanwhile Donald Trump has
been endorsed by Kid Rock and Stephen
Baldwin
a Baldwin you think about so little you
didn't realize that's not Stephen
Baldwin that is Stephen Baldwin now
Trump Trump to be fair Trump has also
received endorsements from an angry owl
in an abandoned barn and the sound of a
motorcycle peeling out of a White Castle
parking lot so that's good that's good
now in the spirit of the season I
personally am ready to make a few
endorsements as well not for president
of course owner because of my accents
the only elected officials I can endorse
are Prime Minister's viceroys and
magical railway controllers but that
doesn't mean there aren't things outside
the realm of politics that I would like
to formally endorse starting with
obviously animals wearing people clothes
I'll fish aliy endorse you you are
charming and a wholesome delight unlike
people wearing animal clothes which is
generally a specific sex thing
now in the same vein I will give my
unqualified endorsement of interspecies
friendships like these dog and goat BFFs
and this unlikely pairing of Tilda
Swinton and a human from Earth you are
both endorsed it is official I'm also
happy to get behind gingham shirts with
ties that you wouldn't think go but
somehow kind of go take it from me by
the way you really want to get someone
to pick those out for you or you are and
finally I would like to endorse pushing
tin yes yes pushing tin the air traffic
control movie starring John Cusack and
Billy Bob Thornton and I'll tell you why
because if you are looking for a snooze
in the middle of an overcast Sunday
afternoon pushing tin will knock you the
couch endorsed officially dot that is
all for now we are back on July 24
goodbye
you